العلاقات السعوديه السوريه
اهم البنود للبيان المشترك
التوصل الى حل سياسي للازمه السوريه
اهميه حل الصعوبات الانسانيه وتوفير
البيئه المناسبه لوصول المساعدات لجميع
المناطق في سوريا تهيئه الظروف اللازمه
لعوده اللاجئين والنازحين السوريين الى
مناطقهم تعزيز الامن ومكافحه الارهاب
بكافه اشكاله وتنظيماته تعزيز التعاون في
مكافحه تهريب المخدرات والاتجار بها دعم
مؤسسات الدوله السوريه لانهاء تواجد
الميليشيات المسلحه والتدخلات الخارجيه في
الشان الداخلي السوري تحقيق تسويه سياسيه
شامله للازمه السوريه بدء اجراءات استئناف
الخدمات القنصليه والرحلات الجويه بين
البلدين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات